hey what's up guys it's Rob and welcome
to my tutorial for the most pocket ninja
star this is an all-new ninja star that
I made together with Jeremy Shafer a
parallelogram flicker you want you can
check out mr. Torres by clicking on the
card above the cool thing about it is it
has all these pockets on both sides and
if you want to make different size ninja
stars you can slide them into the
pockets like that you can also join two
of them together like this or even
connect four of them together just like
this I'll show you how to do that at the
end I recently went fishing and caught a
nice-sized blue and gave myself a
much-needed haircut if you do like the
video don't forget to give it a thumbs
up and click the subscribe and
notification belt stay notified I've
also been working on making my own ninja
sized sword so if you want to learn how
to make this let me know in the comments
below you'll need two sheets of any size
square paper I'm going to be using these
colored printer sheets that I have but
if you want to use origami paper you'll
also be able to get a checkerboard
pattern on the ninja star once you have
the paper let's get started the multi
pocket ninja star is made with two
mirror-image pieces which get
interlocked on both sides like this
similar to the original origami ninja
star to make the printer sheets into
square sheets just take the top edge and
align it with the left side and then you
can cut or tear the excess off to remove
it so you have two square sheets with
the diagonal fold since the two units
are slightly different I'll go through
the steps to make both at the same time
so you can understand it easily since we
have a crease going this way in the
paper we're going to take the upper left
corner and fold it down to the bottom
right corner make a nice sharp crease on
the left side and do the same exact
thing with this one now when you open
them both you'll see that we have an X
in the paper now we can take the two
opposite corners and fold it directly
into the center so just line it up and
make a crease on the upper right and
then take the bottom left corner fold it
into the center and crease it on the
bottom as well do the same with the
other sheet fold the corner into the
center give it a crease and then fold
the opposite corner into the center as
well and crease it so far they're made
the same exact way we're just going to
flip them over now
now we're going to fold these opposite
edges into the center so just fold it in
making sure that the edge is lined up as
you can see this line should be on top
of itself and just make a crease as you
can see there's a little triangle that
stays on the back we're do the same with
the other edge just fold it in and make
a crease so it should look like this do
the same with the left piece just fold
the two edges directly into the center
and crease well now that it looks like
this we can then flip them over and this
is where we're going to make them
slightly differently I'm just gonna set
the paper so that they're horizontal and
looking at the paper you'll see that we
have these triangles make sure that
they're folded all the way on this line
like this and you'll notice that there's
a vertical line and that should lie
directly on top of the crease that's
already in the paper so just make sure
that the triangles are all the way fold
it in like that now I'm gonna set them
like this and I'm gonna fold the left
side here down onto this vertical line
so left side is going to go down like
this onto that vertical line and I'm
going to make a crease on this one the
left side is going to go up onto the
vertical line so just fold the bottom
edge up onto the midline and give it a
good crease on the lower left now this
one on the right is going to get folded
up on the line and this right side is
going to get folded down on the line so
as you'll see they are complete mirror
images and even if you flip it upside
down it's still the same thing now we're
going to flip the units completely over
just like this and we're going to turn
the piece on the left into what I call
the S piece looks like an S and the
piece on the right will be turned into
the Z piece because it looks like a Z
and to do that we're just going to fold
the outer edges here on top and bottom
inwards just like that so take the left
piece and we're just going to fold this
corner here and this edge should line up
with this one fold it in like this line
up the corner
and this edge should be parallel with
the bottom one just like that make a
nice crease and as you'll see you should
see a little diamond or box in the upper
left here and it's okay if you have
space here on the bottom right now I'm
going to do this edge and this one this
corner meets up with here just like this
and give it a crease now for this piece
we're going to take the upper right and
fold it in and give it a crease and the
bottom left and fold it up just flatten
everything out and then we're just going
to take these two top flaps and fold
them down and the bottom ones and fold
them up just fold it down flatten it out
and fold this whole flap here upwards
and flatten it down crease and up crease
so you should have two pieces that look
just like this one of the cool things
about the units is because they have so
many different pockets on them they
actually have a horizontal slit or
pocket here on the front and what you
can do is lock it with itself by folding
this tip down sliding it in like that
and folding the bottom tip up sliding it
under here like that and this is what we
call the flick parallelogram or
parallelogram flicker and what you could
do with this is kind of hold it like
this and hit your finger against it and
make it fly like a frisbee or you can
hold it like that on the table and then
flick it so you could try that out if
you want to interlock them what we're
going to do is we're going to hold both
of the units like this and I'm going to
turn the one on the left completely
upside down then I'm going to rotate it
so that this vertical crease or vertical
opening here is horizontal so just turn
it just like this then I'm going to put
the left one on top of the right one and
as you'll see when I do that if you lay
it down on the table you should see they
cross like this they form like an
X and what we're going to do the bottom
unit now I'm going to take this flap of
the bottom unit and I'm going to put it
underneath here lift this up take the
top flap here and fold it down
underneath the blue one like that then
we could take the other bottom read unit
and slide it under here by lifting that
up then we could flip it over as you'll
see we can kind of move this around a
little bit to make it a little easier
for us so just move it until this edge
right here this edge is not being
blocked by this edge of the paper this
corner here so if it's like this just
shift it like that until you have enough
space to move it then we could fold it
down like this and this one gets folded
down like this now as you'll see the top
one is going to go to the left side
under here and the bottom one is going
to go on the right side under here so
just kind of curve it a little bit like
this slide it into here and then curve
this one like this and slide it to the
right side in that little pocket then
you could flatten everything out and you
have finished your multi pocket ninja
star there are a ton of different ways
that you can connect them and it looks
really cool I can't go over all of them
but I will explain a couple before I do
that the smaller ninja stars here that I
made are made from quarter sized squares
so I just took a eight and a half inch
square folded it in half both ways and
cut it along the midline to get four
sheets which I made two ninja stars from
so to do that with different colors you
can get something like this so these are
the smaller ones if you look at the
ninja star you'll see that there are a
whole bunch of these weaker one layer
pockets in the middle here and there are
what I call strong pockets on to tips
per side so these two are the strong
pockets as you'll see there is a slot
here on the left and one on the right
and it's made from two layers so it's
pretty thick and it is a snug fit if you
take a strong pocket tip hold it like
this and take the other one on the left
here then you could slide these two one
of them into there like that to get
something like this once you lock two
like that then what you can do so if you
join two just like I showed you do the
same with the other two and then you
could take these bottom tips find the
strong pockets where are they oh okay
there's one here that you can slide it
in like this and then there's one
there's actually two here so you can use
this one here on the right or this one
here on the left it doesn't really
matter just gonna slide it in like that
and there you go so it holds pretty well
and you get something cool like that so
it's like a was it one two three four
five six pointed ninja star almost so
there's a whole bunch of different ways
that you can do it you can experiment
with it as I showed in the stop-motion
you can also put it in here if you want
in the the weaker pockets something like
this just play around with them and have
fun I'll show you how to throw it but
basically we're just gonna hold it like
this and flick it so here's how to throw
them so just put your finger on the tip
here
I hope you guys like the video for the
multi pocket and interlocking ninja
stars if you did don't forget to leave a
thumbs up down below and a comment let
me know what you guys want to see next
do you want to see the ninja Sai this is
challenging model of the bike design but
it looks awesome I gotta admit and I was
thinking of making like a life-size one
like maybe like that big if I can I will
put a pole up but it seems most people
want to see more boomerangs so let me
know what you guys want to see if you
want to see boomerangs a new cardboard
boomerang new ninja star boomerang some
people have said they wanted to see a
transforming ninja star boomerang or a
transforming boomerang I'd have to
really try and work on something but
yeah leave me a comment and let me know
what you guys want to see next the most
I'd like to thank Jeremy for working on
this video with me again I hope you guys
are all staying healthy well and
enjoying your summer don't forget to
click the subscribe and notification
bell if you're not already and I'll see
you guys soon